今日はドクター
はじめだ
釘で今日も科学の実験をしていこうともうちょっと内力聞いたんだかこちら皆さん覚え
ているだろうかべある焼きそば国元気カラーカ月ある通りです泣けるほど痛みが強いの
で小さなを求め神にがてなかったは食べられ
十分ご注意ください私結構速いに動画とったんだがいろんなユーチューバーともが猛虎
橇のこぞってくって痛い思いをしてて
多くの方がこれの家墓も吸ってると思うんですよを食べてる人も食べてない人もすごい
ンってホントにマジで食べたことないった人生の経験として超食べて欲しいから本当に
勝手ですそっとそういうレベルじゃないくらいかわいいですよ本当にまあ人によると
思うですけども私はドイツ無理でした方がいいんですけどねこれ食べた動画の後ユニー
たすぎて病院行こうか迷うそれ本当にきつく
辛いの苦手な人なんですけど本人がしゃべってるんだちょっと思い出して辛いすです
どんな問題にも交代は取ったのでそんなことやビっているために共和国激辛ぺ案を
美味しく食べれる物を見つけようと思います
さあ何個食うことになるでしょうかはいとだけでもどんなに辛いものでも何かと
打ち消し会えば必ずプラスマイナスゼロになるですこれも輝くの方程式って言うんで
いろんな食材準備したのでブーク激辛と何かを組み合わせて安全に食える会の見つける
マネージャーをやっていこうと思いますでは行こう
よって指でまずは普通に食ってみましょう
ほんとの空への家なんですよだからこそ俺は答えを見つけるために頑張らなきゃいけ
ない誰もこれぐらいでも相当ヤバいと思っていますかんだきます
ああああああ
だった
j
おっす
はっはっは
あーやばいばねほんと無理なんてこれやはりところから本当に作ってアイゼンあのは
そっちに行くと
her 2れけど
はうん
rar
野球チャンプは元とくればとまたんで奄美と酸味を活かしていい感じ体を消してくるん
じゃないかなと思います
結構かけないで止めこんなもんでどうでしょ混ぜますん
いい感じの絵付けしたのではないでしょうか動い溢れ出てますけど多分俺大丈夫だと
思いましたそれに行ってトマトって甘いもの
えええっ
[音楽]
ああああああ
はいこれ勝機あるんじゃないでしょうか
卵って結局すべての食べ物マイルドにするとあると思うねうまいこといい感じになる気
がするんですよね割れとガッツリちょっと民気がするのはこんなもんでどうでしょうか
栗と君予防麺に絡めとって完成です卵ってもなくマイルドの代名詞みたいのがあります
からねいただきます
ん
dee
me
[音楽]
大荒れからずないですすごい束をかなくないこれが辛くないわけじゃないよこんなから
来なかったら不安になってくるけど
のっ
走り壊れるん
rar
バンドやってな優しいじゃあの味わいが多分のいい感じにね内気しちゃってくれると
思うんだですよね私メル便だとまぁ実際のとかどうなんかわかんないですけど
混ぜます
いいんじゃないよなんかすごい冷やし中華みたいな感じなりました
ああ
実は限界ですイタダキマスターどうやってる
[音楽]
踏まえ
辛い辛いは前後面から岩からへ米今やなんでもないから e 5位
こんなに出た音はを包み込む人たちはでもおらんと思っている私はこれでに味でねまぁ
の家になんなかったらもうね不思議をドーンと行かせていただきます混ぜます
すごくなってこんなんだ浄化されて言ってるんだろうなどうでしょう
いただきます
me
うんからなんでーマヨネーズに家気ねーじゃーん
全然マヨネーズがあるんですけどなんかすごいからすぎて貫通しているイメージが
すごいあげました結果弱
me
世の中でそばめしって言われるほどご飯と焼きそばのシーンは背が高いんですよなぜ
かっていうとお互いの良いところを空けし合うから
合っちゃっていいかなこのペースだと普通に動くべきから23ハグクーペたんですけど
大丈夫だよね混ぜていきたいとおもいます
こんな感じでいかがでしょうか結構薄まってると思うんですよね
強いちょいですよねぇー
であげようリカちゃんだといい感じになってるん
がーーーーーーーイ百歩譲って来られナムをつけちゃってねぇなんなら可能さが
引き立ってるまである気がしますこれ
もうネタだった思うじゃないですかーてもネタじゃないんですよあまり辛すぎるんで
これくらい対等の甘さのものを持ってこないとダメな気がしてきました全部捧げに
もったいないんでつかある程度を入れていきたいとおもいます
シンプルめっちゃ好きなんですよバカみたいに食ってた昔に目また違ってこい
ファイプッチンプに甘いからそれそうの良い勝負できると思うんですよね
負けるなーたないだねうわぁ
あー店だけ払いたくなってきたんでは食べようと思いますいただきます
[音楽]
とっていっ
あえっ
カラー前で官ら何でああ
ぶーからねぇここまでで分かったことは甘い月だとどうしようもないまである気がし
ました
全戸 ripe チップえんまり
といいつつのそこで負けないのがはじめチャット6人でダメだったらもっと甘い
もの好きするんですっこれくらいってさぁ
中に入れてもあまりの天田に気づかない説あると思うんですよ
そういう申し込んでみます中に俺は災いだと思いますこれでいきましょういただきます
[音楽]
teinen 2
この甘いとかじゃなくてその滑り気があるかな僕激辛のからそぬ女にとって辛さを抑え
てくるような気がします
どうぞ
うわぁせばコーティングされて起毛面がをいただきます
[音楽]
ヒューズあーあわあああああ
辛いわかないけどほんのりこんなに船が雑感動画あっつ犬 kura です今日は根本
的な辛さは無いですこれ
いや優勝をヘタレなこれすごいわ
金でいけるなら私もいけるだろメープルシロップです8緻密でいけるってのウィンカー
ショップもちろんのこと大丈夫気がするんですよねはい
のでしょいきます車間行けるんだけどこれはいけるマジで
になります
ぶっこ
んの
none
あああああん
me
うううう
me あった
入っただけでいかがだったでしょうか私の体感なんですけどもハチミツで一番有効だっ
て気がしますね味がちょっとあのあんまり
えって感じだったんでアジアを求めるのであればまあケチャップとか卵とかも工賃的に
すごく食べやすかったってもうどうしてもご供花企画エンド食わなきゃいけない状況が
来たらそこら辺使って食べてみてはいかがでしょうか
もう二度と食いませんじゃん